oonh this is an incredibly busy route
the main route that people would use to
get to the Port of Dover or get the
Channel Tunnel you can see here these
the latest pictures that we have from
the scene and you can very clearly see
there where this pedestrian bridge has
collapsed onto the westbound carriageway
between Junction three injunction for
heading towards London and you can see
there that it's almost inside the back
of a lorry it appears to have ripped the
top off of this lorry and certainly
police have described how they believe
that the lorry collided with the
pedestrian bridge and that's why then
collapsed onto that side of the road now
we've also throughout the afternoon had
some pictures and videos from people who
were on the scene very quickly after
this incident happened one of the videos
that we've had through shows half of the
bridge they're still hanging very
precariously over the eastbound side of
that carriageway the other side of
course you can then see the lorry
completely with its roof ripped off but
still at that moment you have got the
traffic moving past now another video
that we've also had through you can see
there the traffic has then been stopped
you've got the fire service and now
there and also you can see a little bit
in the background potentially people
being treated by paramedics now the
police have confirmed that only one
person has been injured in this incident
which actually is incredible when you
think just how busy the m20 was this
afternoon you can see there the air
ambulance as well coming in to land but
in terms of what the police have said
they said that one person has been
injured their injuries are not
life-threatening and also that they
don't believe that anyone else has been
stuck within the debris which has been
caused by this collapse we've also
spoken to a few people who were on the
scene as well one of them was Kalpana
Fitzpatrick who spoke to us very shortly
after it happened what we can see right
now is a truck two trucks and squashed
by this bridge and emergency services
are on the scene and treating from what
I can see one person and there's quite a
lot of people sort of looking around on
the motorway quite not knowing what's
what's happening basically but beside
that I'm on bridges
hang in so obviously all the traffic's
been stopped and yes it's all kind of
them big bit shocking and Rhiannon in
terms of the traffic consequences you
alluded to earlier a hugely busy weekend
this isn't it
and Kalpana they're saying very shocking
for them but I think what people are now
going to be dealing with is huge tale
banks in that area